oh oh it's happening
hi guys as you can tell I'm still in
London please ignore the trash then
flash scum palace that is mamrie Hart at
my hotel room we have learned that we
are incredibly gross so we haven't
learned that this is just common
knowledge memory lasagna that fell on
the floor last night we're as desperate
as we are disgusting I'm in London and
today I was buying some stuff that we
needed for our show tonight our nofilter
show that we're doing and I had a chance
to do a little person or show up things
so I thought today I'd do a haul video
it's always fun to see the things that
you don't have yourself content I went
to boots which is a misnomer there are
no boots inside this store this is
London's like CBS convenience store this
you see yes yes yeah this is batiste dry
shampoo I did not take a shower I took a
shower I wash my body not my hair for
tonight's show
and I use this and it works so well
which in hindsight I should have washed
my hair because I got a lot of Coors
Light sprayed into it on stage last
night as desperate as I am disgusting I
like my shampoo like I like my vagina's
dry whoa great starts next I got this
you see I see yeah you see this is lando
lips it's moisturizing lip balm because
I've been drinking a lot here in London
my lips are very dehydrated got this
because gold for the Queen and it has a
sheep on it yeah you can see that
perfectly can't you it's got a cartoon
sheep on it with human lips with
lipstick unfit so if sheep love this
product
so do I because I'm a human sheep oh I
got this you see I see yeah you see this
is tough go fresh spray shampoo why is
it so dirty on the outside so I got
gross on it do you know it's really
dirty I didn't notice that god it's
deodorant that sprays get in there
sorry I mean you're welcome hurry then
duck downtown can't dance and pants that
I went to Primark for the very first
time and Holly why am I never been to
this store before this is the greatest
store I was having the happiest panic
attack of my life when I walked in I
have an idiot I came back I was like
married look at what I got and I showed
it it's this you see I keep seeing you
see and I was like this is cute and
she's like yeah I saw that there but I'm
just not a huge fan of the Rolling
Stones and I was like uh it's not just
lips and tongues it's a reference to the
Rolling Stones I'm an idiot poser
terrible you see me wearing it my
explanation is that it's my dad's
favorite band then of course I got this
because I couldn't not because it's the
stupidest thing then I got yes okay
sandy see ya can't see ya this is a
dress I'm like look how shapeless it is
I love it it's like having a denim
pillowcase on my body and I'm so excited
about it it's got like flowers on it so
it's like look I thought about I thought
about being a lady or it kind of looks
like someone in the street passed me by
and just like tripped with a bucket of
bleach and just it got all over me
Joe Texas you see as you see yes yeah I
hate this i hate when people wear things
that say los angeles in new york and
brooklyn and london and all that on them
but for some i like green and i like
athletic like baseball t type of things
so I feel very mixed about this but I
bought it ha yeah next is to CFC yeah
you see yeah it's a necklace with a
[ __ ] bow on there and then it's like
Oh Harry excellent use of forehead bow
neck this see if you say F you say a
generic oversized muffs which shirt
nothing else to say about it I'm super
into it
get out and that's in it that's the end
of my haul I had a whole lot of fun now
I have to go get ready
and do the show because memory will be
upset if I don't get upstairs to their
room to leave on time II I don't know
wait oh my god I'm a [ __ ] idiot I
forgot about the greatest purchase of
all time that I made this
you see I see yeah you see a Tuesday
Union Jack onesie primary guys like
12,000 floors to it and I kept telling
myself don't go up to the next floor
grace Helbig don't don't don't you do it
oh you stand you're on the escalator
okay and when I was going up the
escalator I looked up to my left and I
just saw this hanging taunting me
telling me I'm yours
I mainly bought it so I could wear it
for the show tonight and then we're
doing a show in Dublin tomorrow so don't
you guys have the same flag